[Music]
[Applause]
is Dave Roberts with us he is okay
Dave can you hear me
I can how you doing Dan I'm good good uh
it's uh let me give the full intro here
the LA Dodgers manager Dave Roberts only
took off the hat looking good there
yeah you know what the hair is trying to
come through a little bit yeah
have you had it long before
uh I I have
um back in uh High School I was all I
was known uh by many as sort of El
Debarge
the long hair the fuzzy mustache and
then the hair coming out of the back of
the helmet uh Joe Montana was my
favorite player so as a former
quarterback on one of the hair so it was
just a bad bad look I always wanted Fred
balitnikov hair the uh the Raiders wide
receiver because he I don't think he had
much on top but it came out of the back
of his helmet and I was like yeah yeah
that that's right that's why I sort of
went Joe Montana you know it just kind
of it looked cool the curls coming out
of the back of the helmet have you met
Montana
I have not um I had a chance to meet
Jerry Rice uh and Steve Young last I
think it was last year up in San
Francisco but I'd never I've never had a
chance to meet uh the great Joe Montana
uh help me understand how you get your
team together to get them acclimated
with the new rules and you know pitching
hitting ships all the size of the bases
uh do you have a seminar of you know a
PowerPoint with your team
I think what we've done is uh we have a
morning meeting every day in spring
training and uh pretty much every day
every other day we have uh
you know Bob Garen uh kind of talks
about the rules and we get feedback we
get dialogue with our players and I
really like that you know as football
players they get in like that class
classroom setting and so
um I I think that so we have video some
PowerPoint and just kind of really
trying to belabor the rules the points
and how we can adjust because it is an
adjustment you know the pitch clock for
hitters uh they seem a little sped up
understanding how pitchers can use it to
their advantage the basis the
non-shifting and all that stuff the
little intricacies of the rules that I
think the more we talk about and players
talk about it it only kind of cements
more and lands better well it feels like
the pitchers might have a little bit
more of an advantage because they can
control the at-bat Far More Than The
Hitter can used to be the hitter could
step out adjust all of that pitchers
waiting now it feels like the pitcher
has a little bit more control do you
agree the pitcher does and uh
the pitcher does have more control it's
going to be a tougher adjustment for the
hitter and I think Max shares her a
couple days ago guys are talking about
how he had the baseball ready to go and
then once you get ready to go and then
whether out of the full wind up the
stretch
uh you can hold the ball and so as a
pitcher that's an advantage uh hitters
hate pitchers holding the baseball
messing up their timing and pitchers
like hitters like Rhythm and so most
guys don't practice the holding of the
baseball to then deliver a pitch so
those are things that if you can kind of
tighten stuff like that up and get
familiar with it
um it could really be an advantageous to
the pitcher what what can you take
advantage of as a manager this year with
these new rules
I I think honestly
I can take advantage of more time with
my family more time to drink wine
because shorter games
um but with respect to the game of
baseball I think it's just more of
the low hanging fruit is just educating
our players because I think that
um the more you get familiar and talk
about it it becomes commonplace so I
don't think there's one thing that we
can sort of game
um you just gotta be really uh you know
you got to just prepare your players so
I don't I don't think there's anything
you know that we can sort of game it was
a little over a year ago when we had
John it was March 24th and you uh you
made your prediction
here is how it sounded with the uh
Dodger manager Dave Roberts
the Dodgers will win the World Series if
we play a full season and there is a
postseason
wait we are winning the World Series in
so I know where you're going with that
no what do you win the World Series this
year put it on okay
put it on record
uh and you know what but and that's fair
but what you did do is you did cut up my
caveat of having if our starting
pitching stays healthy so I I understand
what she just did there so I can play
I'm on the the pitch clock right now I I
wanna
it's media I get it Dan
um I'm not gonna say we're going to win
the World Series in 2023. I still
believe that I really do and
um I don't think there's a manager that
has a really really competitive team
that doesn't feel that way our guys feel
that way yeah but I didn't have a
problem I would hope
everybody else did oh yeah you you
guaranteed a World Series and I mean
like if I'm managing the Dodgers yeah
we're going to win the World Series and
we should have that mindset starting now
and I don't have any problem if you said
I don't think we're going to win the
World Series you know that that's news
saying that you you that we're going to
win yes I want that from my manager yeah
exactly and that's the the people that
know and that have uh you know
understand this sentiment behind that so
uh
we had a heck of a year uh but we didn't
finish did you get in trouble but did
you get yelled at for uh that guarantee
by anybody no I did not okay um I'd like
to think my days of getting getting
yelled at uh are over so no I did not uh
the you'll win the World Series this
year if
we uh play good baseball throughout
October
how about that that's not as scalding of
a hot take as I would like but you know
okay I'm just trying to I'm sorry to
just why don't you think about me Dave
why don't you think about me on this
show that we could get some publicity
yeah you know you've done you've done
very well for yourself my friend and so
I did my part last night I'm gonna leave
it up to another Major League manager
how about that do you yell at players
no no I don't
um I I think I've just learned I guess
as a former player that you know a lot
of times when a manager a head coach is
yelling at a player I think a little bit
they get more satisfaction and
um than trying to get the message to
land with the player and so I think for
me I've always tried to make it about
the players so we have some tough
conversations
um but I do it kind of behind the scenes
um I just never wanna I never wanted to
be embarrassed and I don't think that
anyone ever wants to be embarrassed I'm
always amazed when I watch a basketball
coach who is preaching discipline
but then gets mad and gets animated and
starts yelling I'm thinking I know with
my kids if I would yell at them or if I
would talk to them in a certain voice
the certain voice got through to him
when you start to yell it's like they
tune you out uh or the you know or you
give them a look and it's like no that's
that's not that's not good let's talk
about this they're like oh boy I'm in
trouble
yeah yeah exactly and I think you know
with with uh obviously with basketball
and football and baseball the culture is
different and we're playing 162 games
and it's a different pace granted this
year the pace of play is gonna be a lot
quicker but I still I'm with you Dan
it's like the yelling you start to
become uh on the starts to land on deaf
ears and so I think for me I look and
how we go about things that's something
more I'm more critical of and um you
know you got to find a way to make
players uh want to play the right way
and and uh put forth the right amount of
effort it's great to talk to you and uh
you know we were at Giants stadium in
Scottsdale for the Super Bowl and
just letting you know it was the
convenience of it we had a nice setup
there and they gave us the entire
stadium so I did feel like I was
cheating on you a little bit uh but I
will say that you know they had t-shirts
already made up that had to do with
hating the Dodgers well I appreciate the
honesty
um I'm still trying to get past that SC
Banner behind you that so I'm just
trying to like I'm still trying to uh
come to grips with that so I appreciate
it wait I put I put two kids through
school I deserve something from UNC
and I didn't get any discount you know I
it was like full boat I had to pay for
these two
that's fair um so I'm gonna I'm gonna
brag about my daughter who's at Stanford
and I got a son at Lola Marymount so uh
I'm almost out of the woods with one and
so uh I'm gonna be uh enjoying life once
my daughter gets out of school yeah
what's Stanford set you back
uh I I want to say it's I think my wife
does all the billing I think it's 70k I
think that's that's uh I think that's
the load number probably right you
better win the World Series Dave
[Laughter]
guaranteed sort of they're going to win
the World Series uh great to talk to you
thanks for uh all right Dan take care
man that's Dave Roberts Dodgers manager
take a break back after this